so there's now a growing republican
movement to impeach Donald Trump it's
not huge but it's there and it's getting
bigger it's bigger than it ever has been
and one of the people's sort of at the
front and center of this Republican
movement is Republican congressman
Justin Amash who is saying what are
actually pretty obvious and
uncontroversial things although within
the Republican Party they're certainly
rare things like Oh
Trump's Attorney General William bar
misrepresented the Mulla report shocking
and in a sense for a Republican to say
it it's progress and Justin Amash is
saying it and he should be applauded for
that but the most notable thing about
all of this is that he's now saying
straight up Donald Trump should be
impeached he had a town hall in Grand
Rapids Michigan yesterday I believe and
he got a standing ovation and at least
some small part of the Republican Party
at least the people going to his Town
Hall and clapping is increasingly behind
the movement to impeach the President of
the United States here's just a little
bit of video from this event I'm
confident that if you read volume 2 you
will be appalled at much of the conduct
and and I was appalled by it and and
that's why I stated what I stated that's
why I came to that conclusion because I
think we can't go we can't let conduct
like that go unchecked Congress has a
duty to keep the president in check and
it is a difficult process for those who
are worried about you know Congress
intruding on the President's powers
consistently it is a difficult process
to remove someone from office it's not
easy so no one's suggesting that just
because you start some inquiry or
process that a person's remove from
office nonetheless we have a job to do
and I think we owe it to the American
people to to represent them to ensure
that the people we have in office are
doing the right thing are of good
character aren't violating the public
trust this is a Republican who's saying
this it's
but it's something and of course Donald
Trump immediately over the weekend and
continuing to just bash Justin Amash
personally with all sorts of insults
tweeting quote never a fan of Justin
Amash a total lightweight who opposes me
and some of our great Republican ideas
and policies just for the sake of
getting his name out there through
controversy if he actually read the
biased Muller report composed by
eighteen angry Dems who hated Trump he
would see that it was nevertheless
strong on no collusion and ultimately no
obstruction anyway how do you obstruct
when there is no crime and in fact the
crimes were committed by the other side
Justin is a loser
who sadly plays right into our opponents
hands so bottom line okay one Republican
member of Congress says it's time to
impeach it's a big deal in a sense but
it's also not nearly a big enough deal
to actually get anything moving however
will Republican senator Ben Sasse join
might I don't know Republican senator
Mitt Romney join in Romney was recently
asked about Justin Amash saying it's
time to impeach Romney said it's
courageous for him to say it but that he
doesn't actually think impeachment is
warranted at this point in time there's
the idea maybe Mitt Romney could be
swayed on that Ben Sasse is a Republican
senator from Nebraska who's been a big
critic of Donald Trump and there are
rumblings that maybe SAS would jump on
board with calling for impeachment but
it's very very speculative at this point
so we will just have to wait and see as
far as that goes now as far as a MASH is
concerned this guy is no progressive
hero right it's really important to
understand okay he sees Trump for what
Trump is but a MASH is like an extremist
cartoonish small government guy his
voting record is atrocious so this is
not praise of Justin Amash beyond just
here's a guy who's a Republican but he's
not getting in line
with the partisan position on Trump
period and that's it right is it likely
that a mash is going to be the start of
a landslide Republican movement towards
impeachment no it's not likely is it
possible a mash is the start of a small
subgroup of Republicans who by joining
the removed Trump side may be damaged
Trump for 2020 that's more reasonable
and I think that's what we have to
understand you know let's we have to
have expectations setting that's
reasonable our Republicans going to
fully jump on board impeaching Trump no
there does not what we can hope for is
that the Republican impeach Trump Trump
movement grows just enough that it
starts to kind of chip away at Trump and
become a thorn in his side in his quest
for re-election in November of 2020 and
maybe does some actual damage